[Applause]
what's happening you bad mother [__]
this Friday night swinging dick and
giving out chopsticks if you're watching
this you should be out living your life
not watching some fat [__] but don't
worry about nothing we got you covered
you know same it's always a party here
a ring-a-ding-ding [__] uncle
Joey here calmly ones green room my
little Goomba each is here with me
Lisa at one Denver the first show was
tremendous pass where the [__] were you
now the second show be a lot better you
understand me why because this
preparation about the people from xxx
came by whatever the [__] sixty and
dropped off a little [__] energy
drink you don't meet dog I come prepared
I bring my own hello TKO tushies
I had the meal bring him for me about a
week and a half ago cuz that's how I
roll why [__] fly with weed when you
can let ups do it for you you know
saying the leap of the [__] legal
mule
you're looking good [__] it's
Friday night you're home
I just wanted to tap and layin on and
forget about you know I love you
[__] with all my heart I got bad
news here punch drill Alabama has been
canceled I got some TV [__]
okay I got stuck on a butt here but
we're all right now we're back but you
just want to check in with you and let
you know it's Friday night do you think
the week is over it's time to relax and
go out and stab a [__] I gotta
get a new joint you know I'm saying I
got like 22 in my pockets don't matter I
just want to make sure you people alive
and kicking and celebrate a little took
they don't put you in I'm saying do a
little [__] at the beach so nobody
gets their feelings hurt here on a
Friday night again there you go we go
deep into the murky waters always on
stage or stage it don't matter
you when you got the uniform on you got
a rock with it you follow me and the
uniform is always on then you go lee-sia
a little something to get you going
throughout the night I just want to
check in with you got chuckling you know
I love you I'm with you you're with me
and they want to be with us with savages
don't worry about nothing anyway
we're here at the Denver calmly works
you [__] up I told you to get tickets
don't [__] around no more they tell you
on Twitter to get the tickets get the
tickets see people are savages they got
computers their fingers their fingers
are quick you don't want to get finger
banged by these people these people
[__] you to death but that's what
Friday nights are all about the Guam
dengue [__] get chlamydia do
whatever you need to do you're young you
only got one life don't sit there in
front of a TV hold on me look at me who
gives a [__] if you got an ATM card you
got blank checks you got money [__] it
take a chance come up as dead it's time
you got a felony and I'm saying
anyway I just want to check in with you
we're doing great here green chile I
didn't eat meat today let you know I got
observed I got observed because if not
you got problems later on I'm in that 50
zone I gotta watch the religious aspect
of life I don't want to be caught with
my pants down in hell you following me
with a picture Dana white on the wall I
don't need that [__] I got [__]
happening anyway the podcast is back
next week
Nayak New York I'm still coming March
21st they're gonna add a shell don't
[__] around I'm telling you these people
lunatics they don't give a [__] what
night it is Tuesday Thursday the church
goes out 7:24 we're on a mission we
don't sit around no more we're doing our
thing slinging dick and giving out
[__] Rosa with Rosa and McGowan pills
with any Rose McGowan PSTD dick pills
I had the Chilean seabass zero points on
Weight Watchers you follow me the zero
points with the new system like
cheeseburgers zero points for [__]
fish young chicken zero you understand
me
look at me I'm looking tip-top Magoo I
went over the [__] what's-his-name's
kickboxing class today in Denver very
nice people very nice people
I might go again tomorrow at a digital
tournament so I might do beginning
jujitsu or [__] do the Muay Thai I'm
not sure you know me I'm trying to keep
it together 55 I'm still alive swinging
dick with a dream you follow me I'm like
Martin Luther King without the marching
band he's following me [__] let's do
this [__] if you're under 18 get off
this [__] go jerk-off go do a
biology reporter so I'll be a little
[__] go to a term paper on Denmark to
something go find out where they make
cheese and something
but you're not gonna learn nothing here
this is for adults only so anyway that's
it and that's that I don't know what
else to tell you I'm out of words I'm
floored I'm back to where I started I
started this joint 1991 first time I got
on stage and Here I am like a [__]
sad like I've thrown out of here for
sexual harassment which was false
accusations that's why I'm a man of many
accusations but not a lot of convictions
you follow me you want to convict me but
I show up with 12 [__] does
Uncle Joe you don't give a [__] no more
go Pete please can I go pee now me I'm
gonna pee now and you believe the pen
you pee in the bucket that might be last
night no no you pee in the bucket it
mixes in with the ice anyway you know I
love you
you know I'm a [__] solid soldier
here I'm not trying to sell you dick
I don't give a [__] I just want you to
understand about life we don't give a
[__] we take the bull by the horns we
show up in the lion's mouth put a chair
in there and say lick my balls with your
little jagged tongue
anyway I got big things to do and people
at sea and I'm saying but I wanted to
check them when you let you know I
didn't forget about you [__]
you're my heart and soul
you keep me writing jokes you keep me in
shape
you keep me you keep me tip-top Magoo
because you got me in check you
understand me
nobody's ever had me in check but you
guys watch me watch myself now you made
me a better friend to myself you follow
me and I owe you for that so anyway I
just want to tell you I love you have a
good weekend don't believe nobody Isis
is still out there shooting BB guns and
[__] keep your eyes open don't trust
nobody [__] them all [__] them
and always remember why run down and
[__] one of them when you can walk down
there and [__] them all that's the word
of the week and for the Spanish speak to
people watching all you they didn't get
my mother Lima room the AIA Cantina get
my mother people I literally leo
cause I'm totally I saw with local
evilness I'm PC my god I call it Uriah
Bogota hero a tapas are cool anyway
don't forget to preorder the corporation
TJ English on Amazon that's my boy and
beside that I love you [__]
with all my heart I'll see you Sunday on
the Lord's Day check-in get your gold
straight do your twenty two push-ups and
get ready to rock we wanted to murky
[__] waters you understand me I got
one more show tonight and then two
tomorrow with done but Denver beautiful
city I apologize to you personally
licked the [__] state of Colorado I
behaved when I lived here I was a common
[__] thief but just what I came back
and now I'm a gentleman
believe it or not anyway I love you
[__] I'll see you next week
stay black and remember you got the
world by the balls smile you got nothing
to be sad about you're alive [__]
there's little black kid
flies all over in Africa right now there
you are in your couch complaining that
you having a bad day go [__] yourself
alright I love you
stay black he's back he's back I'm
pissed now you finally wanted pissed
alright I'll see you guys Sunday night
Sunday afternoon we'll check in with you
oh that's right that's how we do it i
fumigate the place I gotta let them know
the spirit of uncle Joey's in the house
I always lie to joy than any cop I go to
you all lock me up lock me up but I'll
be on an hour in a year you'll be
walking the beat in Alaska dressed warm
[__]
Scarface 84